Florian Philippo le vice-président du
Front National et la tête de liste pour
ce parti à l'élection européenne du 25
mai dans l'est de la France et l'invité
de PR par 3 bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de Public
Sénat avec l'Agence France Presse
adémotion avec ce soir Guillaume Daudin
et bien sûr P interno est-ce que votre
liste est prête monsieur Philippo ah oui
elle est prête plus que prête non je
vous parle de la liste des joueurs
français pour le Mondial de faute
d'accord il y apparaî-il 60 millions de
sélectionneurs peut-être vous aussi
est-ce que vous aimeriez ah non je suis
jamais fait partie de ces 60 millions
c'estes 60 Milon mo-1 ça doit être moi
alors est-ce qu'il faut néanmoins exiger
selonon làedans pas très bon c'est vrai
mais si je vous demande par exemple
est-ce qu'il faut exiger un test de
marseillaise au joueurs français
euh non mais je préfère quand il
chanteent à marseillaise
fr évidemment comme tous les Français je
crois François Hollande ce mardi a
refusé en Arménie de commenter a-t-il
dit les polémique ridicule au sujet du
reproche qui a été fait à Christian
tobira de ne pas avoir donc anentonné la
Marseillaise alors qu'une soliste
l'interprétait mais je je ne comprends
pas très bien le fait de justement de de
de ne pas commenter cette cette affaire
parce que ça n'est pas totalement
anodant contrairement à ce qu'il dit je
crois que ça a choqué beaucoup beaucoup
de Français euh le bon qu'elle ne chante
pas la Marseillaise ostensiblement
qu'elle refuse de la chanter ça vous
l'acceptez vous acceptez l'ipè pu puiss
VO on par choisir le le recueillement
plutôt que l'interprétation soi-même
avec parfis les j'ai vu son explication
totalement alambiquée le recueillement
trois petits points plutôt que le
caraoké Destrade donc elle considère que
les autres ministres faisaient faisaient
du karaoké quoi je veux dire c'est c'est
voilà d'abord on comprend pas très bien
ce silence et surtout ensuite ces
explications explications de Madame
tobira sont pour le moins surprenantes
voir inconvenante je veux dire dans
n'importe quel autre pays un ministre de
la République un ministre qui parlerait
ainsi de l'hymne national serait
débarqué dans l'heure dans l'heure il
démissionnerait par desessens où il
serait débarqué elle ne veut pas
démissionner mais normalement François
Holland devrait prendre ses
responsabilités je ve dire derrière la
Marseillaise c'est évidemment un symbole
de la France de la nation de la
République mais c'est aussi un champ sur
lequel beaucoup de résistants sont morts
ont été fusillés ils l'ont anentonné
pendant qu'il
d'être tu je dire c'est un ch qui
raisonne Audel même des frontières de la
France qui raisonne pour l'ensemble des
Patriotes du monde qui sont attachés au
valeur de liberté cette polémique est né
le 10 mai dernier puisque c'est la date
anniversaire du vote de la loi tobira
justement sur l'abolition de l'esclavage
il n'y a pas eu de commmémoration cette
année dans la ville que vous détenez
dans l'INE enfin pas officielle pas par
votre
mère comment est-ce que vous jugez cette
attitude mais si vous
voulezanchement non mais moi moi un peu
l'analse mar c'estàd que moi je pense
qu'il faudrait non mais c'est vrai je
pense que peut-être qu'il aurait dû y
aller puis que non c'était pas stupide
mais je comprenais j'ai compris ce qu'il
voulait dire oui B c'est son expression
mais j'ai compris non c'est pas mon
expression j'ai compris ce qu'il voulait
dire il en a un peu plein le dos de si
vous voulez de la repentance permanente
la culpabilisation de la France et des
Français c'est vrai qu'on en a marre je
ve dire tous les 3 mois on nous explique
que la France a très mal s très mal
comporté dans le passé sur tel ou tel
point au bout d'un moment stop on a
aussi une histoire glorieuse qu'il
faudrait mettre en avant bon ensuite je
pense surtout quand on lutte contre
l'esclavage parce que c'est quand même
le signal qu'on veut envoyer légitime il
faut parler de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et l'esclavage aujourd'hui
malheureusement ça existe toujours dans
le monde ça existe par exemple au Qatar
voyez on parlait du foot bah il y aura
une coupe du monde je crois de football
en 2022 au Qatar il y a un chantier des
chantiers un peu partout là-bas en cours
il y a des immigrés indiens par exemple
il y a 400 immigrés indiens qui sont
déjà morts sur le CH sur les chantiers
du Qatar voilà ça ce sont des esclaves
modernes et et et voilà moi je serais
allé à cette cérémonie puis j'aurais
j'aurais parlé de l'esclavage moderne
d'accord bien vous y seriez en tous les
cas allez en ce qui vous concerne CIN
jeunes Français partis pour le djihad en
Syrie il y a quelques mois je juste sur
un terme que vous avez employé le mot
polémique sur Madame tobira ou on dit
polémique à toutes
les polémique ridicule a dit le chef de
l'État c'est ridicule de sa part de pas
y répondre surtout mais c'est pas une
polémique tout n'est pas polémique il y
a des il y a des sujets de qui font
partie du débat politique madame tobira
elle est ministre elle est responsable
de ses actes de ses écrits de ses
paroles elle doit s'en justifier s'en
expliquer il y a pas de polémique
là-dedans il y a simplement un débat
cinq jeunes Français qui étaient partis
faire le djihade en Syrie il y a
quelques mois ont été interpellés à
Strasbourg ce mardi matin qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ces jeunes
endoctrinés déjà le phénomène est
manifestement encore plus important
qu'on l'imaginait cela nous donne ça
donne raison aux analyses que nous
faisons sur l'ampleur du phénomène qui
concerne des centaines de jeunes
Français l'ampleur et l'ampleur
l'ampleur du réaction de la réaction du
ministre de l'Intérieur également c'est
assez faiblard déjà il a fallu le temps
pour qu'il prenne conscience de
l'existence du phénomène pour qu'il
l'accepte et et et ensuite pour réagir
nous sommes aussi à quelques jours des
élections européennes donc on sait qu'on
va probablement multiplier les actions
médiatiques et les Français ne sont plus
tout à fait dubles de cela parce qu'il y
a pas de politique cohérente dire il
faudrait normalement renforcer les
moyens du renseignement français le
renseignement alors ça a commencé avec
la révision c'est grâce à eux qu'ils ont
été interpellés oui bien sûr mais je on
met pas en cause le travail des
fonctionnaires du renseignement qui est
qui est tout à fait remarquable mais
depuis Nicolas Sarkozi avec la la
révision générale des politiques
publiques la RGPP que les fonctionnaires
connaissent bien on a effondré les
moyens de l'État dans un certain nombre
de domaines notamment le renseignement
où on a effondré les budgets et les
moyens humains et et matériel bon là
c'est un vrai un vrai problème parce
qu'on a besoin du renseignement ensuite
il faut il faut lutter beaucoup plus
fermement contre ce phénomène là
surveiller les prêches faire en sorte
que quand on sait qu'un jeune est parti
là-bas faire le djihad et bien quand il
revient je préfère qu'il revienne pas
pas mais bon si jamais il arrive à
revenir qu'il soit surveillé qu' soit
que l'arsenal le juridique soit
judiciaire soit considérablement
renforcé voyez et puis ça pose le
problème de notre diplomatie parce que
en quelque sorte on on lance le signal
quand on nous explique que les gentils
rebelles en Syrie il faut les soutenir
qu'il faudrait presque les armé et
intervenir militairement pour les aider
par on parle pas des mouvements
dihadistes par on parle de l'autre
opposition les rebelles donc on parle de
5 % des rebelles eu ceux qui ne sont pas
islamistes ou djihadistes l'immense
majorité des Rebell
sy son islamistadist et notre diplomatie
les a soutenu publiqu alors des esprits
faibles jeunes malébl peuvent tomber
dans le panneau alors vous dites il faut
repérer notamment par exemple les
conversions rapides des jeunes Français
c'est l'appel qui a été lancé par dalil
bouaker aux imam et vous pensez que les
imams peuvent faire ce travail de
repérage également dans les
mosquées les imam sont pas des
fonctionnaires de
l'État on peut on peut pas faire
confiance non plus à tous les
imam ve lutter le disent contre la VI
oui oui oui mais il faut aussi
surveiller les prêches voyez euh et puis
ce phénomène là je pense qu'au bout d'un
moment il faut avoir l'honnêteté de dire
aussi qu'il est lié à une immigration
massive voilà en large partie lié à une
immigration massive alors je vous parle
des jeunes convertis hein oui oui il y a
des jeunes convertis il y a pas que des
jeunes converti puis même les jeunes
convertibles se convertissent pas comme
ça par hasard c'est qu'il y a un climat
c'est queil y a des quartiers entiers
qui échappent quasiment à la loi de la
République au bout d'un moment parce
qu'on a accepté la communautarisation on
a accepté que les règles d'un Islamist
radical s'impose aux lois de la
République dans certains quartiers et
bien évidemment à partir de de là bien
les esprits encore une fois les plus
maléables les plus influençable
notamment chez les jeunes peuvent tomber
dans ce genre de dérive gravissime on
sait que ce type d'embrigodement hélas
n'est pas réservé à la France he
puisqueil y a des centaines de jeunes
Européens qui sont partis et qui partent
et tentent de partir pour la Syrie mais
l'immigration massive n'est pas réservée
à la France même si prend une part
considérable est-ce que vous vous
imaginez ne pas arriver en tête le 25
mai et avec quellees conséquen politique
selon vous vous ah il est possible qu'on
arrive pas en tête je on a on a lancé en
tout cas un objectif audacieux c'est
d'être premier parti de France et
d'arriver en tête ce je crois a créé une
émulation intéressante maintenant nous
ferons de toute façon un très bon score
voilà je rappelle que notre record
historique concernant le Front national
pour les européennes date de 1989
c'était il y a 25 ans et c'était 11,7 %
VO la dernière fois nous avons fait nous
avions fait 6,3 c'était en 2009 là les
sondages nous mettent je ne sais pas à
20 22 23 24 nous verrons bienité
peut-être devant l'UMP avec de toute faç
on a v manuel Vals s'engager fortement
est-ce qu'il prend un risque inconsidéré
selon vous mais je crois que Manuel Vals
sétait engagé fortement déjà au
municipal pour le Parti socialiste bon
on a vu le résultat il n'était pas
encore Premier ministre alors je demande
à Manuel Vals de s'engager encore plus
considérablement encore plus massivement
et le désastre électoral pour le PS sera
encore plus considérable et encore plus
massif c'est une sorte de machine à
perdre j'ai le sentiment manuel vas
alors donc la nouvelle poussée du Front
national estest points puisque j'ai vu
que sa popularité était déjà en début de
chute libre vos espoirs bien s'appuyent
notamment sur les sondages effectivement
qui sembleent indiquer une nouvelle
poussée du Front national pour
l'élection européenne pourtant il y a eu
un sondage BVA le Parisien qui indique
que plus de 7 Français sur 10 sont une
mauvaise opinion de Marine Le Pen alors
comment est-ce que vous expliquez ce
paradoxe puisque une majorité assez
forte hein la juge agressive démagogique
raciste une minorité moins d'un tiers
seulement visionnaire et sympathique
c'était pas plus de 7/1 mais c'était un
peu moins de 7/10 peu importe euh ben
écoutez c'est un sondage qui mesure déjà
le bruit médiatique quand effectivement
dans l'ensemble des émissions quasiment
on dit que Marine Le Pen et tous les
qual qualificatif que vous avez employé
quand ces adversaires politiques tous se
coalisent en permanence contre elle et
contre nous on est leur obsession
aujourd'hui il y a plus une intervention
du même du président de la République ou
du Premier ministre où on ne parle pas
de Marine Le Pen ou du Front national ce
qui est tout de même extraordinaire vu
vu la somme de problèmes réel concret
qui se pose au pays et qui devrait être
la priorité des responsables politiques
je dire nous nous-même quand nous sommes
dans dans les débats moi quand j'ai en
face de moi un PS un UMP un centriste un
vert un Front de Gauche peu importe au
bout d'un moment et très rapidement il y
a systématiquement une coalition et les
téléspectateurs le voient alors
forcément on mesure le bruit médiatique
mais ça n'est pas très important je veux
dire ce qui compte ce sont encore une
fois les sonnages d'intention de vote
qui sont très bon c'est la dynamique
qu'on ressent sur le terrain c'est la
dynamique des idées voyez ou de la
désespérance sociale bah il y a de la
désespérance sociale et il faut il faut
recréer de l'espérance en France non
mais recréer de l'espérance en France ça
suppose d'avoir un projet concret de
redress
national je crois que nous sommes les
seuls à créer cette espérance et même
les seuls à être capable de remettre des
abstentionnistes aux urnes et ça c'est
aussi pour nous un motif de satisfaction
mais il faut continuer vous voyez on
parle de sondage l'Eurobaromètre qui est
sorti aujourd'hui c'est la sauf qui fait
un sondage dans tous les pays de l'Union
européenne nous explique que
l'euroscepticisme monte encore que le
sentiment national monte dans la plupart
des pays on le voit en France par
exemple en France il y a plus que il y a
plus que 28 % des Français qui font
confiance à l'Union européenne contre 63
% la force de choisir des Bou émissaires
mais c'est pas un
bouémissaire vous parle parle les
immigrés personne n'a jamais parlé des
immigrés comme un bou émissaire les
immigrés sont responsable de rien
d'ailleurs immigrés je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire parce que dans les immigrés
vous avez des Français vous avez des
étrangers donc je n'aime pas ce terme
les l'immigration l'immigration comme la
soumission à l'Union européenne les
seuls responsables ce sont les
gouvernements français par exemple quand
ils ont bafoué le vote des Français sur
la Constitution européenne en 2005
gauche et droite confondu quand au
Parlement ils ont fait annuler le vote
des Français et ils ont fait voter le
traité Lisbonne là ils ont pris une part
de responsabilité historique en Bou en
bfouant le CH des françaisUn des combats
du moment hein c'est le fameux traité
que négocie l'Europe avec les États-Unis
pour un traité de libre échange
d'ailleurs c'est un combat que vous
partagez avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
était à votre place il y a 15 jours avec
nous et le Front national selon vous
doit-il voter la la proposition de
résolution du du Front de Gauche donc à
l'Assemblée le 22 mai pour exiger
l'arrêt immédiat des négociations oui il
la votera oui mais bien sûr mais vous
savez nous on est eu ils sont sectaires
eux ils sont sectaires si on proposait
quelque chose qui va dans leur sens ils
ne le voteraiit pas par principe quitte
à faire du mal au pays voyez et au
travailleurs français si nous nous
estimons quelqu'un propose quelque chose
qui va dans le bon sens même s'il n'est
pas du tout de notre bord politique on
le vote voilà en l'occurrence on le vote
moi je préfère qu'on soit plus nombreux
à à à combattre ce traité pour espérer
le faire capoter notamment au Parlement
européen que moins nombreux comme je me
réjouissais par exemple en 2005 encore
une fois sur la Constitution européenne
et bien dans le nom il y avait toutes
sortes de familles politiques mais au
moins ça a permis au nom d'être
majoritaire vous saz à côé ça à côté de
ça le PS et l'UMP eux aussi partagent un
combat mais ils partagent le combat pour
se traité transatlantiqueusez bien sûr
l'expression d'extrême droite est-ce que
vous allez un jour aller jusqu'à récuser
l'expression de
droitetion bien sûr mais le Front
national n'est pas de droite il n'est
pas de gauche il est aussi éloigné de
l'extrême droite que de l'extrême gauche
il est patriote et et vous savez le le
clivage gauche-droite je pense qu'il est
dépassé en réalité depuis très longtemps
voilà moi je suis je fais partie d'une
génération qui a qui a grandi dans des
dans d'autres enjeux c'était fini le mur
de Berlin c'était fini euh euh la guerre
froide ou quasiment c'était sur la fin
euh c'était fini le bloc de l'Est et et
et le et le monde libre et cetera et
cetera je je veux dire moi j'ai grandi
dans un monde qui était confronté aux
enjeux de la mondialisation et là il y a
pas de gauche il y a pas de droite aux
enjeux de l'Union européenne et on voit
bien qu'il y a pas de gauche il y a pas
de droite euh aux enjeux de de la
question de la nation la question de la
souveraineté la question des frontières
économiques financières migratoires il y
a pas de gauche il y a pas de droite sur
toutes ces questions là voilà et la
question de qui redonnera au peuple
souverain au peuple français sa capacité
de maîtriser son destin et sa monnaie ou
sa monnaie mais ça fait partie du destin
a pas de gauche il y a pas de droite il
y a les démocrates et il y a ceux qui
sont pas démocrates nous nous sommes
démocrates comment expliquez-vous que
malgré sa valeur peut-être
cert trop élevé l'euro permet à l'Union
d'être excédentaire aujourd'hui dans ces
échanges exemple l'Allemagne avec un
excédent commercial je vous je vous vois
sourire vous dites est je connais
l'argument l'excédent 200 milliards en
Allemagne c'est bien que c'est pas
l'euro la cause c'est peut-être nos
faiblesses nous en France nous somes
nous nous sommes déficitaire mais oui
l'Union européenne globalement la zone
euro globalement est excédentaire parce
que l'Allemagne est excédentaire mais
parce que l'Allemagne est que
l'Allemagne d'autres pays la France des
RAR à être déficita l'Allemagne c'est
c'est le gros morceau de l'excédent de
la zone pour une raison simple c'est que
l'euro est batti pour l'Allemagne je
l'euro c'est le Deutsch Mark 2.0 si vous
voulez non non l'euro est batti pour
l'Allemagne et d'ailleurs Madame Merkel
a dit il y a quelques jours ou il y a
une semaine l'euro fort protège la
vigueur des exportations allemande Mme
Merkel elle parle pas des exportations
européennes elle s'en moque elle parle
des exportations allemandes elle a bien
raison elle défend les intérêts de son
pays moi ce que je reproche à nos
dirigeants c'est de ne pas défendre les
intérêts de la France l'euro n'est pas
adapté à la France alors il y a 3 mois
on nous expliquit que l'euro n'était
même pas trop fort c'est nous peut-être
qui ne sommes pas adaptés du la
compétitivité exigé aujourd'hui pour le
problème de compétitivité aujourd'hui
c'est notamment la question de l'euro il
y a pas que ça mais il y a la question
deur mais vous savez on a progressé il y
a 3 mois quand on disait que l'eurau
était trop fort on se faisait insulter
aujourd'hui au moins ils admettent tous
que l'E est trop fort arrêtez de dire
que vous faites toujours insulter
hein je ne sais quoi c'est de l'insulte
on va parler plus avant d'autres grands
enjeux de ce scrutin du 25 mai Florian
Philippo avec la poussée du vote
contestataire qui devrait constater
également partout en France avec
conséquences bien sûr pour votre
mouvement l'ambition de sa présidente
mais avec peut-être un renforcement du
coup des alliances au centre pour
permettre la poursuite de la
construction européenne que vous
dénoncez le sujet de Jérôme Bonard avant
Guillaume dadin notre confrère de la
FP vendredi dernier à bzier la
présidente du Front national boostée par
des sondages favorables affiché ses
ambitions partir à l'assaut du Parlement
européen et créer un groupe avec
d'autres partis d'extrême droite pour
certains adversaires
ce n'est pas crédible non il pourrait
venir à 100 110 120 ils bloqueront rien
du tout ils feront un grand cinéma au
Parlement européen quand ils sont là
parce que je dois quand même dire
jusqu'à présent il faut bien dire qu'à
part deux ou TR jours de session plinère
on ne les voit pas beaucoup et j'ai même
remarqué des endroits où on voit le
Front national voter avec le Front de
Gauche en fait 25 € députés issus de se
étatmembres suffisent pour constituer un
groupe politique permettrait d'obtenir
plus de subventions mais d'ici à peser
au Parlement cela reste à prouvver le
véritable problème c'est combien de
temps ce groupe durera sachant que nous
avons affaire à des mouvements qui
traditionnellement ont des agendas
nationaux qui ne sont pas nécessairement
compatibles car même si Marine Le Pen
peut compter sur quelques alliés comme
le populiste et islamophobe néerlandais
J wildilders ou encore le FPO autrichien
d'autres partis comme le Britannique et
europhobe yukip refuse de s'associer à
un mouvement qu'il juge trop extrémiste
au final face au bloc solide des 751
eurodéputés l'onde de choc des extrêmes
n'aura peut-être pas lieu ce qui serait
ennuyeux c'est s'il n'y avait plus entre
les socio-démocrates les centristes et
les
socioliibéraux des une majorité
suffisante pour faire avancer l'Europe
qui a toujours marché à coup de
compromis entre une gauche modérée et
une droite modérée mais après le 25 mai
prochain il faudra certainement laisser
quelques sièges supplémentaires aux
europhobes et autres eurosceptiques qui
dans de nombreux pays caracolent en tête
des sondage et où il pourrait arriver en
tête ou en seconde place voilà Guillaume
Dodin de lap est avec nous bonsoir
Guillaume vous suivez le Front national
pour l'Agence France Presse hein c'est
une rude mission vos questions à
Monsieur Philippo ça bonsoir Florient
Philippo on a vu dans le sujet qu'il y
avait quelques alliés européens dont on
a parlé donc il y a le le FPO autrichien
flams bang la la Ligue du Nord aussi le
le Parti de la liberté de Ger
wildilders il y a d'autres personnes
avec qui vous êtes en discussion les
démocrates de Suède le Parti national
slovaque ma première question c'est de
savoir ce sera une alliance politique ou
une alliance technique que vous comptez
faire au Parlement européen ce sera une
alliance politique sur l'Europe sur
l'Europe ENF sur tout on n pas en accord
sur tout ça n' au une importance
d'ailleurs puisque chaque partie a son
histoire son contexte national et on on
on n pas bâti de programme commun loin
de là non en revanche on est d'accord
sur la question de la souveraineté
nationale par rapport à l'Union
européenne le fait de retrouver notre
liberté par rapport à ce machin
bruxellois qui est en échec total et qui
en plus est profondément dans son
essence oligarchique qui n'est pas
démocratique c'est ça le problème alors
ça nous permettra d'avoir un groupe il
faut SEP nationalités et 25 députés nous
y travaillons et nous sommes optimistes
de ce point de V là du coup vous allez
peut-être vous alliez par exemple avec
donc le parti la liberté de G Wilders
ger Wilders il est connu pour ses
déclarations choc qui crée des des des
des qui qui crée comment dire des
problèmes contre lui parce que par
exemple il a déclaré récemment il y a
trop de marocains au Pays-Bas on va s'en
charger il a été largement critiqué au
Pays-Bas pour ça ou alors il a comparé
dans le passé le corant à mcamp pour
vous c'est un c'est un allié qui ça
reste un allié possible c'est je veux
dire on n'est pas responsable de tout ce
qu'il dit voilà il s'en explique je
crois qu'il s'en a expliqué mais encore
une fois je me aucune responsabilité
dans ce que dit g wildilders ou
quelqu'un d'autre ça comme j'imagine
qu'au PS on va pas regarder
l'intégralité des déclarations de
l'ensemble des membres des partis alliés
au PS dans le cadre du PSE je suis pas
sûr
vousouerez pas déclaration le chef du
PSE en ce moment c'est le c'est le chef
du PS bulgare et ils sont alliés à
attaka qui a un mouvement d'extrême
droite en Bulgarie vous voyez ou mais je
sais pas si vous ce petit jeul on peut
aller très très loin mais ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens est-ce que vous auriez
accepté au sein du Front national
quelqu'un qui mais il est pas au sein du
Front national mais il est pas au sein
du Front nationalou mais vous vous
alliez avec lui c'est quand même en soi
déjà c'est pas une alliance du tout
programmatique c'est une alliance pour
faire un groupe sur un point précis qui
est la question de la souveraineté par
rapport à l'Union européenne mais encore
une fois on a bien compris le le petit
jeu mais je veux dire faisons ce jeu je
pense sans aucun intérêt pour l'ensemble
des partis alliés à l'UMP dans le cadre
du PPE ou allié au PS dans le cadre du
PSE et on peut trouver exactement la
même chose c'est facile de faire ça mais
ça n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt moi je
suis pas gvilders et je suis pas du tout
je suis pas néerlandais je suis pas de
son parti donc je me sens aucune
responsabilité dans ce qu'il dit ce que
je vois c'est qu'il est en tête dans son
pays il est surtout il est surtout en
tête dans son pays donc ce qui les
Néerlandais doivent pas être
monstrueusement épouvantés par par
Monsieur wildilders et ils doivent
adhérer à des idées qu'il défend
j'imagine il y a aussi sinon il serait
pas en tête après de 30 % des non mais
vous savez aussi il y a quand même une
poussée de la xénophobie partout en
Europe donc ça peut aussi porter des
candidat c'est gris de lecture
moralisante il y a pas de soyez
politique ne faites pas de la morale en
permanence non il a il y a un débat sur
l'immigration si vous parlez de cela par
exemple il y a pas de montée de la
xénophobie il y a un rbol vis-à-vis
d'une immigration massive qui crée des
problèmes économiques sociaux et en
terme d'identité voilà je ve dire c'est
un problème qu'il faut traiter
politiquement il faut pas stigmatiser
les gens en disant vous êtes raciste ou
je ne sais quoi comme il faut traiter la
question de l'Union européenne sans dire
qu'il y a des bouclmissaires c'est pas
parce qu'on considère que l'Union
européenne a trahi l'ensemble de ses
promesse qu'elle ne marche pas du point
de vue économique social industriel et
ou même V l'immigration avec Schengen
qu'on stigmatise l'Union européenne ou
qu'on en fait un bou émissaire on a le
droit de débattre c'est pas une entité
métaphysique l'Union européenne c'est un
c'est un objet politique qui a défini
des choix et des priorités par des
traités des directives et des règlements
et ben on les discute et nous on
considère que ça ne va pas du tout que
on est la zone qui fait le moins de
croissance dans le monde et qu'il faut
réformer tout ça très très très
profondément vous critiquez souvent le
le PS et l'UMP sur les affaires qui les
touchent parmi vos probables alliés il y
a aussi l'ancien président lituanien
Rolandas paxas qui a été destitué pour
des faits de corruption dans son pays ça
vous paraît aussi une alliance je sais
pas aucune idée alors là je sais même
pas quoi avec de qui et de quoi vous
parlez et ça m' futurs all je suis pas
lituanien voyez moi la différence
peut-être avec les autres c'est je
considère que les Français ça existe enc
peut-être dans un même groupe oui mais
je serai représentant français au
Parlement européen je serai pas
lituanien voilà donc il s'arrange avec
ses affaires ça n'a strictement aucune
importance pour moi très bien vous du
coup vous dans ce futur C cherche des
affaires pareil je veux dire des alliés
d'autres pays du PS et de l'UMP qui
qui sont confrontés à des affaires il y
en a des tonnes il y en a des tonnes je
pense pas que vous demandez à Monsieur
Copé ou à Monsieur kambadellis ou
repsen sa responsabilité en matière
d'affaires en Autriche en Allemagne
Royaume-Uni ou je ne sais où les les
autres partis enfin coalition
européennees présentent des candidats
pour la Commission européenne donc il a
Monsieur Schulz pour les socialistes
monsieur Junker pour les les
conservateur pourquoi le le Front
national n'a pas voulu présenter de
candidat avec ses futurs partenaires
pour la commission parce qu'il il démit
toute légitimité à la Commission
européenne d'accord mais vous vous
démiez il me semble la légitimité de
l'Union européenne pourtant vous lui
présentez des candidat non nous allons
nous avons la possibilité de peser au
Parlement européen bien sûr parce que là
il y a des textes qui sont discutés
parce que il y a la possibilité de faire
entendre la voix de la France parce que
nous serons les probablement les seuls
avocats de la France et du peuple
français parmi la délégation française
parmi les 74 députés et que les autres
j'entendais monsieur Cavada qui disait à
quoi ils serviront les députés Patriotes
du Front national à quoi il sert lui il
est dans un groupe de combien 200 300 il
appuie sur le bouton pour voter toutes
les directives que que ses maîtres
bruxellois lui fournissent et lui
demande d'avaler bah il sert à quoi
Monsieur Caval
rien et bien par exemple on pourra se
battre sur les élargissements à venir de
l'Union
européenne est-ce que vous aurez le poid
pour nous ferons tout pour et quitte à
avoir des majorités de circonstances
bien évidemment mais l'intérêt général
prime sur le reste et il faut absolument
qu'on se batte contre les élarg à venir
Balcans Turquie sur le traité
transatlantique qui est dramatique pour
l'agriculture pour l'industrie pour nos
normes sanitaires alimentaires et cetera
il faut qu'on se batte sur des sujets
extrêmement concrets contre l'austérité
aussi qui est pas une pour moi c'est pas
une fatalité l'austérité il y a d'autres
possibilités il faut relancer la
croissance par un autre modèle
économique ce qu'on
beaucoup
partout je vois le résultat oui
j'entends même le PS dire non à
l'austérité c'est leur slogan de
campagne en fait il faut comprendre non
à l'austérité en Europe mais mais oui à
l'austérité en
France monsieur Vals que répondez-vous à
Jean-Claude Junker qui a déclaré qui
vote populiste ou extrême droite vote
pour les paroles creuses ce sont des
voix perdues il parle il parle où dans
le cadre du débat luxembourgeois euh oui
il parle dans une interview au Monde là
que j'ai sous les yeux ah oui je sais
pas monsieur Junker n'a pas de leçons à
me donner voilà qu'il donne des leçons à
ses amis luxembourgeoins j'ai pas de
leçons à ressoir de Monsieur Junker
voyez ni de monsieur schuls qui n'ont
rien à faire dans la campagne française
qui n'ont pas donné de leçons aux
Français qui fait bien de s'intéresser à
la campagne en Allemagne c'est très
intéressant au Luxembourg monsieur fer
ofstad qui est un autre candidat en
Belgique mais ils n'ont pas de en
campagne ce mardi par exemple en
Bretagne ça vous choque il vient je
crois d'ailles à forbac là vendredi
euh ça me choque oui oui bien sûr ça me
choque tout à fait person grat non il
est pas personnal non grat mais que des
des responsables étrangers viennent
donner faire la leçon en français en
leur expliquant queil faut voter pour
tel ou tel parti je veux dire je trouve
ça choquant ou alors qu'il se présente
sur des listes en France mais je trouve
ça éminemment choquant et je je trouve
ça lamentable de la part du PS et pour
l'instant des centristes peut-être de
l'UMP de se faire représenter dans le
fameux débat du 22 mai le seul grand
débat en prime time sur France 2 puisque
le PS veut se faire représenter par
Monsieur schuls l' oui mais c'est parce
que Marine Le Pen a refusé jusqu'à
présent de débattre avec lui en aurait
peur paraî-il bah la preuve elle sera là
c'est pour l'instant c'est celui qui ne
vient pas qui qui a peur les centristes
veulent se faire représenter par
Monsieur fer ofstad je crois que
Monsieur Copé devrait se faire
représenter par Monsieur Junker très
logiquement mais ça prouve quoi ça
prouve qu'ils sont dans dans une logique
supranationale non pas européenne
l'Europe c'est les nations il y a des
Français il y a des Allemands il y a des
Italiens bah non c'est la vision de
partagé je pense par 99 % des Français
l'Europe sont des nations là ils sont
dans une vision postnationale
supranationalez vous dites vous d'près
France et et et moi ça me choque parce
que ça prouve que la technocratie
européiste supranationale pour ces
gens-là pour les responsables du PS du
centre et de l'UMP est plus importante
que le débat la confrontation directe
avec les Français reconnaissez quand
même que les partis qui veulent faire
l'union européenne avance ensemble hein
pays confondu ils avancent reculant on
voit le résultat en faisant reculer les
les acquis sociaux en faisant reculer
l'emploi en faisant reculer la sécurité
en faisant avancer oui l'immigration
clandestine plus 48 % l'an dernier vers
l'Union européenne ce sont les chiffres
de Frontex bref c'est un écheac total
cette machine qu'on qu'on le reconnaisse
pourquoi c'est un on considère que
l'Union européenne est un objet
religieux avec ses dogmes son crédau pr
question une question très concrète
non j'ai votre programme enfin celui de
Marine Le Pen mais c'est un document
commun vous dites c'est un tracte commun
voilà vous dites que les députés Front
national feront en sorte d'organiser un
référendum en vue de sortir de l'Union
européenne voilà c'est l'une des
proposition je voulais juste comprendre
comment un député européen pouvait
organiser un référendum en France pour
sortir l'Union européenne quel est
le plus nous serons puissant et nombreux
au Parlement européen plus nous
enverrons un signal national fort parce
queil y a évidemment aussi une dimension
nationale dans le résultat de l'élection
si François Hollande le 25 mai au soir
et le 26 mai au matin se réveille avec
un un Front national premier parti de
France près d'une vingtaine de députés
français Front national rassemblement
ble marine au Parlement européen il ne
pourra pas se dire qu'il y a pas un
problème avec l'Europe en France oui
mais de là organiser un référendum de
sortie de pour qu'est-ce que ça non de
de l'Union européenne qu'est-ce que ça
d'extraordinaire d'organiser des
référendums et et je sais qu'en France
on aime plus les référendums mais en
Suisse ils en font trois qure par an
utal en font de par an constuer un
groupe vous PZ veulent faire un
référendum sur la sortie de l'un EUR le
fait de constituer un groupe vous pensez
que ça va vraiment changer les choses
que vous aurez vraiment des pouvoirs
d'action sur l'Union européenne nous
aurons des prérogatives supplémentaires
bien sûr et nous aurons des une capacité
de nous faire entendre plus importantes
bien sûr sinon le PS et l'UMP ne
chercheraient pas eux aussi à faire un
groupe il ne seraient pas déjà dans un
groupe un groupe ça permet d'exister
alors ça permet t tout ne changera pas
avec le Parlement européen on est
d'accord mais être plus nombreux plus
visible avoir plus de prérogatives et
toujours plus intéressant qu'être moins
nombreux moins visible et avoir moins de
prérogativ et je crois que les électeurs
français doivent le comprendre c'est
pour ça qu'il est très très très
important d'aller voter le 25 mai si on
ne vote pas on fait un cadeau à ceux qui
veulent l'Europe de la continuité et
vous parliez d'une opposition non
constructive ça veut dire vous êtes prêt
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à à
à voter des mesures qui seraient proposé
par exemple par des élus de gauche mais
comme le font déjà nos députés parce que
par exemple récemment il y a eu une
motion au Conseil régional de Picardie
contre le traité trans transatlantique
que vous dénoncez une motion cignée par
les veres et par le P et vos élus se
sont opposés à celle-ci oui mais parce
que là si vous voulez c'est pas un
conseil régional qui décide de ça autant
au niveau de l'Assemblée nationale ou du
Parlement européen on comprend vous
l'avez dit vous voterez avec conse
régional on est quoi on est dans
l'enfumage le plus total des électeurs
on essaie de leur faire croire que la
Picardie va échapper au traité
transatlantique tout ça est pas très
sérieux puis en plus si ça vient des
vers en partie c'est très hypocrite
parce que les ver c'est un mouvement
européiste vous préférez quand ça ça
vient du Fran gauche non mais
excusez-moi les Verts au moins le front
gauche ils ont voté non en 2005 je crois
bon Mélenchon il me semble qu'il était
sur les les tribunes du du nom autant
les Verts c'est un parti ultraeuropéiste
qui adore l'Union européenne donc qui ne
se plaignent pas des conséquences de ce
qu'il a lui-même créé voilà oui non mais
l'autre problème de Mélenchon c'est
qu'il n'est pas clair sur les sujets
européens je veux dire sur la
souveraineté nationale comme il a un
problème de fond avec la nation il n'en
parle pas sur les frontières comme il a
un problème de fond avec les frontières
il n'en parle pas donc il parle pas du
protectionnisme je ne sais même pas s'il
est protectionniste ou pas nous nous
sommes protectionnistes sur l'euro alors
là il est pour et contre ça c'est le
grand et ça change apparment ça change
c'est en train de changer mais nous nous
considérons que l'Union que l'euro est
un échec et qu'il faut il faut en
revenir à à ce que ce qu'on aujourd'hui
95 % des pays du monde c'est-à-dire une
monnaie nationale adapté à le économie
pour nous ce serait un franc dévalué bah
oui mais c'est bien d'avoir une
dévaluation les Suisses ont fait une
dévaluation il y a 2 ans les
Britanniques aussi résultat les
Britanniques l'an dernier avaient 5 fois
plus de croissance que l'Allemagne tour
une balance du commerce extérieur
déficitaire ça c'est c'est typique pour
le RoyaumeUni on traditionnellement une
balance déficitaire malheus pour les
ÉtatsUnis ai qui maîtrisent leur
monnaie au Japon ils ont dévalué leur
monnaie et maintenant leur balance
commerciale cert mais ils ont le
Royaume-Uni a eu l'an dernier 2 % de
croissance l'Allemagne 0,4 la France 03
moi je regarde les chiffres c'est bien
un franc dévalué alors que la
France ne réalise réalise 90 % ses
exportations au sein de la zone euro est
que je comprends c'est que vous m'avez
dit il y a une demi-heure l'euro est
peut-être trop fort oui c'est vrai
problème donc dévaluer ça veut dire
moins fort
oui pas dans les mêmes
proportions est mal compris ça veut dire
moins fort moins fort par rapport au
dollar d'ailleurs parce que je pense que
le le franc sera un petit peu plus fort
que maintenant par rapport à la lire ou
la PAT qui ont besoin elle d'une
dévaluation plus conséquente par rapport
au dollartional répète souvent que ce
serait bon pour les exportation bien sûr
ce serait très bon pour l'industrie
française et pour l'emploi la monnaie
c'est juste un instrument c'est pas non
plus 10 % de nos exportations hors zone
euro qui conour à notre rich du tout
même à l'intérieur de la Z à l'intérieur
de la zone euro bien évidemment avant
quand nous avions différentes monnaies
nous pouvions jouer de cela par rapport
par exemple à l'Allemagne aujourd'hui on
est mis au régime allemand l'euro je l'
c'est le dutchm 2.0 alors forcément on
est plus compétitif même au sein de la
zone euro mais le coût des importations
par exemple pourrait être enchéri du
coup ça dépend de Al déjà très
marginalement par que pr centimes sur le
prix de l'essence non c'est faux le prix
des produits le prix des produits c'est
marginal c'est marginal dans le prix le
prix des produits c'est marginal dans le
prix global d'un produit enfin le prix
de la matière première bon ensuite par
exemple venant d'Italie ou d'Espagne ce
serait l'inverse concernant l'essence la
grande partie la majeure partie du prix
de l'essence ce sont des taxes de l'État
bien sûr par contre on ne dit jamais ce
que ça créerait comme avantage il faut
lire parle jacqu sapire qui explique les
points de croissance supplémentaires que
ça amènerait et surtout nous arrêterions
nous endetter en permanence pour sauver
tous les 4 matins cette monnaie qui
n'est pas adaptée encore une fois on va
pas s'endetter et payer ADV vitam et
ternam le prix de l'austérité
c'est-à-dire le prix de l'euro merci
Guillaume merci merciine Tarn arrive
maintenant mais juste avant cette
enquête qui a été menée par Marie br sur
votre ascension auprès et même au plus
près de Marine Le
Pen il n'est jamais bien loin de la
patronne sur les photos ou devant les
caméras derrière Marine Le Pen il y a
presque tout le temps Florian Filippo et
pourtant le numéro 2 du Front national
était il y a encore 4 ans inconnu du
grand public et des militants frontistes
c'est vrai qu'il est pas là depuis très
longtemps au sein du Front National et
tout de suite il a été bombardé à un
poste très important donc vice-président
il s'occupe de la communication il
gère en grande partie le programme les
inflexions sur l'euro l'économie plutôt
que sur l'immigration en 2009 Marine Le
Pen rencontre le jeune éarc chez le
souverainiste Paul Marie couteau elle
repère en lui l'architecte de la
dédiabolisation le visage de la façade
respectable du FN il a beaucoup
contribué je crois à modifier l'image
sinon de Marine Le Pen du moins celle du
Front national à travers Marine Le Pen
c'est un peu pour ça aussi qu'elle l'a
choisi non seulement ses compétences
propres mais aussi l'idée qu'il venait
d'ailleurs non seulement de l'ENA mais
peut-être deune tradition qui avait pas
tout à fait sa place jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'URE au Fond
national mais il connaît les rouages de
l'État et participe à la
professionnalisation du Front national
petit à petit le fidèle Florian Philippo
prend goût à la lumière omniprésent dans
les médias mais aussi auprès de Marine
Le Pen je crois qu'il a tout fait pour
se rendre indispensable
oui
et il est devenu
indispensable un dévouement qui lui a
permis de gravir les échelons mais qui
le place également à la mercie de la
présidente du parti du moment qu'il a
les bonnes grâces de Marine Le Pen
Florent Philippo ne craint rien et
forcément flan Philippo il incarne le
renouveau qu'elle souhaite apporter à
son parti mais une fois que Marine Le
Pen en aura marre ou si s'il y a un
différent entre eux il peut très bien
connaître une sortie de route assez
assez rapide au sein du parti beaucoup
espèent cette sortie de route
l'ascension fulgurante et le profil
atypique du trentenaire parisien en
agace plus d'un voilà pine tarno nous a
rejoint bonsoir pine bonsoir Michel vos
questions à Florient Philippo qui espère
que Marine Nura n aura pas marre un jour
de lui puis l'indispensable Florient
Philippo he comme dit Paul Marie couteau
d'ner un petit peu énigmatique comme ça
dans dans dans le reportage c'est vrai
que votre ascension fulgurante au FN a
parfois créé des des tensions des
rivalités pour l'instant vous n'avez
jamais remporté d'élection ça va être
votre 3oè essai cette troisème tentative
C européennes après les législatives et
les municipales en mars dernier à forbac
là ça devrait passer est-ce que cette
élection européenne être élu députés
européens c'est un moyen pour vous
d'assoir votre légitimité au Front
national bon déjà les deux premières
élections on a fait à chaque fois le
meilleur score historique que le front
avait jamais fait dans le coin on a pas
gagné c'est vrai mais on a contribuer à
encrer le mouvement et on gagnera la
prochaine fois voilà alors sur les
européennes c'est pas l'objectif
principal je veux dire l'objectif c'est
d'abord de conduire le mieux possible
cette liste du grand test hein d'en
faire passer le plus possible et on peut
peut-être en faire passer trois je pense
dans l'est et et puis et bien de de
contribuer puisque je suis aussi
directeur national de la campagne des
européennes à la dynamique la plus
importante sachant qu'encore une fois
les Français nous ont rencontré sur la
question européenne mais être élu pour
vous ça va quand même être important au
sein du frond national il y a un congrès
en novembre prochain les militants vont
voter pour élire leur direction au sein
du du front national donc ça vous donne
quand même une légitimité démocratique
non c'est pas un plus au sein du Front
national non mais la légitimité
démocratique elle est elle est
importante tout simplement dans la vie
politique quand on fait de la politique
c'est pour être élu pour exercer des
responsabilités quel que soit le niveau
je suis aussi conseiller municipal et
conseill communautaire et et et pour
faire avancer ses idées voilà ça sinon
sinon moment on tourne en rond
l'objectif c'est évidment d'ê cétait
pour rebondir un petit peu sur le sujet
comme le disait le journaliste il venait
d'ailleurs entre guillemets c'est vrai
que vous aviez un petit peu un profil
atypique au sein du Front National et
que votre ascension a été a été très
rapide donc après avoir été propulsé en
quelque sorte par Marine Le Pen
maintenant il va peut-être falloir
conforter votre place de de numéro 2 non
mais
je je viens d'ailleurs ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que j'étais effectivement
pas au Front national avant de la
rencontré que je me définis moi vous le
savez comme gouliste que je crois que ça
ça fait bon dire Nadine Morano hein qui
dit la gooliste c'est moi ah oui vous
trait de nationaliste elle ou Nadine
Morano problème quand on est en campagne
avec elle c'est qu'il faut en permanence
essayer de relever le niveau quoi parce
que elle tire vers le bas c'est bon
enfin Nadine Morano elle n'est pas
goliste pas patriote non plus parce que
Nadine Morano si elle étaitiste patriote
européenne ah bah oui mais si elle était
égoliste déjà elle n'aurait pas
commencer sa sa campagne sur la tombe de
Robert Schuman premièrement et
deuxièmement elle ne serait pas en
permanence en train de nous expliquer
que la souveraineté nationale s'est
dépassé elle n'aurait pas voté tous les
traités européens et toutes les
directives et surtout Madame Morano
député UMP le 4 février 2008 à
Versailles n'aurait pas voté le traité
de Lisbonne ce qu'elle a fait comme
député UMP et donc elle a voté un texte
qui avait été rejeté par référendum or
vous savez à quel point le général
tenait au résultat des référendum il en
luiême était vitime mais vous êtes un
goliste assez isolé au sein du Front
national Marine Le Pen elle est pas
gouliste non elle se définit pas comme
gouliste mais peu importe je ce qui fait
la force du Front national c'est que
nous sommes attaché à la patrie à la
nation voilà à la France alors certains
se diront républicain goliste patriote
souverainiste qui ne soit pas attaché à
la France à la nation pas t et moi je s
pas les cœurs et les reins je vais pas
dire que tel ou tel ne l'est pas mais je
dis simplement que dans
leentendre non mais je dis dans leur
politique là si je regarde le fruit de
ce qu'ils font et je juge un arbre àez
fruit il n'y a pas de défense de la
France il y a des attaques en permanence
contre la France voilà c'est tout ce
sont des partis PS etump mais aussi les
partis satellit qui gravitent autour
d'eux qui sont leurs alliés Front de
Gauche vert centre et ce des partis qui
ont fait beaucoup de mal à la France
admz que certains considèrent que sortir
de l'Europe c'est effectivement S qui
aime bien Chatti bien mais qui aime bien
Chatti bien je pense que ça s'applique
pas pour un pays voilà est-ce qu'il y a
des sujets qui vous différencient
aujourd'hui de Marine Le Pen est-ce
qu'il y a des sujets sur lesquels vous
n'êtes pas d'accord il y a un point
alors sur le pas sur le le point du
programme parce que le programme prévoit
un référendum sur la peine de mort
euh un choix entre la perpétuité réelle
ce qui est mon option ou la peine de
mort ce qui est son option et moi voilà
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort je
suis pour la perpétuité réel donc ça
c'est votre seul point de divergence
programme on n'est pas à l'UMP he
il y a beaucoup de divergences aussi à
l'UMP l'UMP en ce moment c'est c'est
terrible ouis c'est le grand écar si
vous voulez auparavant avant à l'UMP les
les souverainistes avaient encore le
droit d'en fumer ils avaient une
autorisation d'en fumer monsieur Guen
était là pour pour en fumer maintenant
ils n'ont même plus le droit de parler
on leur on leur on les somme de partir
de quitter le parti B c'est une
formidable clarification qui est en
train de se produire à l'UMP voilà les
déclarations de Monsieur Jupé monsieur
rafarin et Copé à l'encontre de Monsieur
Guo et bien sont une très grande
clarification parce qu'elle démontre que
l'UMP a fait le choix très clairement
maintenant de l'Union européenne
fédérale de la voie fédérale et et d'une
voix qui est très contraire au
souverisme HRI Guen a sa place au Fond
national c'est ce que vous dites moi je
l'ai toujours pensé hein je dis que s'il
écoutait son cœur il serait déjà là
depuis longtemps mais manifestement il a
d'autres ressorts et d'autres motivation
en tout cas on lui a dit quelqu'un non
mais d'autres lui ont dit qu'il n'avait
plus sa place à l'UM
responsable de l'p non mais je lu dis
rien parce que je non mais il fait ce
qu'il veut mais mais mais il y a pas
derrière lu mais autour de c'est pas
c'est pas que Geno si vous voulez il il
y a quand même encore probablement des
électeurs duump qui se sentent
souverainistes patriotes goulises bon et
qui viennent de se prendre une raclée
phénoménale de la part de la direction
de l'UMP qui leur explique qu'ils n'ont
plus leur place dans ce parti bah c'est
ce que j'appelle une clarification parce
que ça faisait longtemps que dans les
faits dans sa politique l'UMP avait
tourné le dos à ses idées nationales un
mot peut-être pour finir de la réforme
sur la décentralisation votre ligne au
Front national c'est communes plus
départements he ça c'est votre schéma
vous vous refusez les les régions est-ce
que ça vous semble le bon levier
économique commune plus département pour
la France alors commune département
ettat nation les autres sont sur
intercommunalité région Europe voyez
nous on est dans la tradition
républicaine alors le ce que nous
voulons c'est que les régions soient
limitées à une une sorte de coordination
entre les départements qu'il n'y ait
plus d'élus régionaux propres ça fera
une source économique aux élections
régionales non il y a encore des
élections régionales à ce moment-là
ouais mais alors pourquoi présenter des
candidats si vous ça serit facile on
laisse la place aux autres non non mais
à ce moment-là les alors les socialistes
ne présenteront pas de candidats aux
élections cantonales parce qu'ils ne
croient pas au département enfin ce
raisonnement n'a pas de sens non les les
régions doivent être une instance de
coordination entre des élus
départementaux mais les mêmes comme ça
il y a plus d'élus propres de la même
manière les compétences stratégiques de
la région comme le transport régional
par exemple où la formation
professionnelle doivent revenir à l'état
parce que le stratégique c'est l'état
alors que les compétences de proximité
comme la gestion Ly doiv revenir au
département et puis il faut supprimer
autre sourceséconomie les conseils
économiques et sociaux régionaux qui
sont comme il faut supprimer d'ailleurs
le Conseil Économique et Sociale
national parce que c'est une source de
gabg énorme et ça ne sert strictement à
rien conseil ne ser à rien du tout les
est-ce que vous craignez comme
jean-fançois Copé que le projet du
gouvernement actue vers plus de
fédéralisme AC une fédération de région
vers un démantellement de la nation mais
je crois que l'UMP ça n'est pas contre
d'ailleurs l'UMP n pas n'est pas
défavorable au projet des grands L
des 11 ou 12 régions qui sont à risque
pour l'unité nationale et qui en plus
entraîneraient des coûts supplémentaires
parce que ce serait les grosses baronies
les grosse féodalité et vous savez qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a fait ça on a créé
des coûts supplémentaires vous interrogé
on la folie grand surtout vos points
communs avec Marine Le Pen vos rares
divergences est-ce que vous partagez la
même admiration que la présidente du
Front national pour Vladimir
Poutine non mais pas de l'admiration moi
je n'admire que les les les personnages
historiques français ah donc pas mais
non mais Marine Le Pen pas on m'a déjà
posé la question mais Marine Le Pen n'a
pas dit ça comme ça elle parlait d'un
point très particulier et je la rejoins
sur la capacité qu'il a eu effectivement
de remettre ça défendre l'intérnational
puis de remettre son pays dans dans le
concert des nations et de redresser
l'État face aux oligarchies c'est pas
totalement terminé hein mais voilà on
peut pas dire que de ce point de vue-là
il n'est pas vuvré pour son pays
maintenant il y a pas d'admiration ou
quoi que ce soit on est dans la réale
politique si pas quelqu'un qui est un
adepte de la manre sortir de la de la
guerre froide c'est mieux on n'a pas de
raison d'être en guerre avec la Russie
même la tente même froide il faut
coopérer avec tout le monde ni ne pas
être sous hégémonie américaine c'est
mieux mais ça veut pas dire être sous
hégémonie russe he certainement pas la
France a sa propre voix et vous estimez
que l'Union européenne doit soutenir
l'élection présidentielle qui va se
tenir en Ukraine le 25 mai je jeestime
j'estime que la France parce que l'Union
européenne je sais pas quel qu'elle peut
dire il y a des intérêts divergents la
France doit faire en sorte que cette que
l'Ukraine préserve son unité
probablement par une fédéralisation du
pays et et que on on évite l'embrasement
voilà al il faut vite trouver
effectivement des autorités légales et
légitimes pour ce pays merci merci pine
merci Florient Filippo merci à vous
merci à très
vite